in this video I'm going to be going over
JSON which is one of the most important
concepts that you can learn as a
programmer or as a web developer I'm
going to be going over what JSON is why
you should know it and all the syntax
involved the JSON and at the end of the
video I'm going to go through examples
of JSON so make sure you stick around
till the end JSON also known as
JavaScript object notation is simply a
data representation format very similar
to XML or llamó it's used widely across
the internet for almost every single API
that you will access as well as for
config files and things such as games
and text editors like vs code and many
many other places throughout programming
it's used because it's extremely
lightweight to send back and forth due
to the small file size it's easy to read
compared to something like XML since
it's much cleaner and there's not as
many opening and closing tags to worry
about and it also integrates very nicely
with JavaScript
since JSON is just a superset of
JavaScript which means anything you
write in a JSON is valid JavaScript so
it integrates nicely with JavaScript
which is used all throughout the web for
front-end or back-end developer
applications also almost every single
major language has some form of library
or built-in functionality to parse the
JSON strings into objects or classes in
that language which makes working with
JSON data extremely easy inside of a
programming language throughout your
programming career you're going to use
JSON all the time whether it's creating
an API consuming an API or creating
config files for you to use or for other
people to use for your application now
that we understand what JSON is and why
it's important let's dive into some of
the syntax involved to JSON by starting
by talking about the types that JSON can
represent as we know if json is a data
representation format so we need to be
able to represent of certain data types
within it and json natively supports
strings numbers and these numbers can be
in any format whether they're decimal
numbers whole numbers negative numbers
even scientific notation numbers it
supports boolean's which can be either
true or false
supports null which essentially stands
for nothing a raised which can be a list
of any of the types that we've talked
about plus the next type which is the
final type of object an object is the
most complex but most used type within
json and it allows you to represent
values that are key value pairs so you
give it a key and then a value and that
value can be anything of the other types
we've talked about so string number
boolean array no any of those different
types can be the value for a key so
let's dive into an example of how to use
json inside of a file the first thing
that you need to do is to create a file
with the dot JSON extension at the end
of it that's dot JSON at the end of your
file and that will create a JSON file
inside of this JSON file what you do is
you take one of the types that we talked
about and you put that inside of the
file so for example you could put a
string you would put a number a boolean
whatever type you want inside of that
file and that's valid JSON but if all
you have is a single string or a single
number it's really not very useful to
have a whole file for that single input
so what most of the time when you're
working with JSON you'll have either an
array or an object as your top level of
your file and then inside of that array
or object you'll have other values so it
may even have other objects have other
arrays or even just individual values
such as strings or numbers inside of
that so let's take an example of a user
object that we want to put at the top
level of our json file which we're going
to call user json to create an object we
need to use opening and closing curly
braces and then inside of that we'll put
all of the key value pairs that make up
our object and every single one of these
key value pairs the key must be
surrounded by double quotes followed by
a colon and then the value for that key
and then if we have multiple key value
pairs we need commas separating every
single one of our key value pairs
similarly to how we would create an
array in a normal programming language
so for example if our user has a name we
would surround that name key in double
quotes put a semicolon after it and then
we will put the value of our name
inside of double quotes as well because
it's a string and it must be in double
quotes and then at the end of that we'll
put a comma because we have other key
value pairs for our user for example if
we wanted to use a favorite number as
another property we will put favorite
number in double quotes followed by a
semicolon and then put that users
favorite number then if we wanted to use
a boolean we use a comma and then
another property we would use is
programmer as our key put a colon and
then we have put either true or false
with no quotes around it to signify that
this is a boolean and not a string so we
had put true or false depending on if
that user was a programmer or not we
could then go down and use hobbies as
our next key value pair so put hobbies
and double quotes semicolon and then to
create an array we use opening and
closing square brackets and inside of
the array we put whatever type of value
we want and in this case we're just
going to use strings for the different
hobbies so we'll put those strings
inside of double quotes and we'll put
commas between each one of them because
we put commas between all the values in
an array or writing out JSON next we can
have another property that'll be an
array of friends but instead of putting
strings inside of this array we're going
to put more user objects inside of that
array so we can put different user
objects inside of that array and now we
have nesting of arrays with objects and
that's how you really get into the power
of JSON where you can start to deeply
nest different properties and really
show a hierarchy of data as opposed to
just a flat format of data like most
data format files give you so for
example for this friends array we could
have a friends array and it can have the
same properties of name favorite number
is program or hobbies and even friends
inside of that and you can start to get
a very deeply nested array if you really
want it then we just have to make sure
that we don't put a comma on the very
last property value key pair that we
have closed it with a curly brace and
that's our full JSON file created now
that we understand what JSON is and the
syntax involved with writing JSON I'm
going to jump into a live example of me
writing JSON file and then parsing that
file in JavaScript so I have Visual
Studio code open
and I'm inside of a file called
companies jae-sung where we're going to
store an array of different companies
and each of these companies is going to
have a name
number of employees a CEO and their
rating out of five so let's get started
by using our syntax for creating an
array which is to use an opening and
closing square bracket and inside of
this array we're going to store
different objects so our first object is
going to be our first company which as
we mentioned has a name and we're just
going to give that company a name of big
corporation and then we put the comma at
the end of the row we want to give it
number of employees as well and then
this number of employees for this big
corporation we're going to say that they
have 10,000 employees then we want to
give them a CEO and their CEOs name is
going to be married and then lastly
their rating out of five stars is going
to be a three point six and now we want
to store a second company in this array
so we just put a comma at the end of our
first company object open up a new
object and then give it the same
properties
so we'll say your name and we're just
going to give this one the name of small
startup go down to the next line we got
number of employees in this case they're
just going to have three employees since
they're a small company CEO is next and
this company does not have a CEO because
they're so small so we're just going to
put null here which is okay to have
different types inside of your JSON
object because JSON doesn't care what
types your different keys are they just
matters that you have keys and values so
we have null here and then lastly we're
going to give them a rating make sure to
put that in double quotes and their
rating here is there's going to be 4.2
or 4.3 and there we go that is our
entire company's JSON object and as you
see we have no errors but if we for
example didn't put the quote here you
see that we get an error and that's
because we're using vs code and it tells
us when we have errors instead of our
JSON so we know that our JSON is always
going to be correctly formatted just
like this is here now it's looking up
this index.html file here which is just
a super simple file that has an opening
script tag
we can put some JavaScript in here to
run on our page so what's create a
variable we're just kind of call it
companies and we're going to copy
everything from this company's JSON
because as I mentioned at the beginning
of the video JSON anything in JSON is
valid JavaScript so we can take this
JSON directly and just paste it in to
our company's variable and then if we go
down here we log the company's variable
and we check that out instead of our
browser here as you can see we have
logged this company's variable and we
have both parts of our array we have CEO
name number of employees rating and all
of this is the information that we have
in this file here that we copied over
into our JavaScript file
and same thing now here we have our
other company but most of the time when
you're dealing with JSON you're going to
get it back as a string and not as an
actual JavaScript object so to emulate
that let's surround this in back text so
there's an actual string and if you save
that you'll see that now our console
just has a string instead of an actual
object and we can't actually use this
object inside of our JavaScript so in
order to convert this JSON string into a
JavaScript object we need to use what's
called JSON dot parse so if we go down
to our log and we say JSON start parsed
and we pass it in a string it'll take
that string and convert it into a
JavaScript object so now as you can see
in here we have our JavaScript object
that we created from this string here
using JSON dot parse to get a JSON
object right here and we can use this
inside of JavaScript for example if we
wanted we could get the first company
inside of that array we could get their
name and now if we say that you'll see
it prints out the first company's name
okay second company's name prints it out
and so on and you can do anything that
you could do with a normal javascript
object to this newly parsed JSON object
that we created with json dot parse so I
hope this video was useful for you as
you can see the actual format for JSON
is fairly straightforward you just have
to mostly remember to use double quotes
around all of your different keys
because in JavaScript you don't need the
double quotes but in JSON you do need
these double quotes
other than that it's very
straightforward it's easy to read which
is great because just looking at this
you can tell what it's representing and
you can tell what the different keys and
values mean and it's extremely
lightweight so when you send it across
the internet through different api's
it'll take up very little amount of
space which means it will quickly send
back and forth which gives your user a
great end experience so thank you guys
very much for watching you now know
everything you need to know in order to
use JSON and consume JSON in your future
projects if you guys enjoyed this video
please like surely leave me a like down
below letting me know and subscribe for
more tutorials similar to this thank you
guys very much for watching have a good
day